R
ITS RESPONSE.
VLAD?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> TURNING NOW TO THE MIDDLE
EAST.
ISRAEL AND HAMAS EXCHANGED NEW
ATTACKS THIS MORNING.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS PUSHING FOR
AN END TO MORE THAN A WEEK OF
DEADLY FIGHTING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOLD ISRAELI
PRIME MINISTER BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU YESTERDAY HE EXPECTS A
SIGNIFICANT DEESCALATION.
IMTIAZ TYAB IS IN SOUTHERN
ISRAEL NORTH OF GAZA.
GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: VLAD, EVERYONE,
I'M ONLY A FEW MILES AWAY FROM
THE GAZA STRIP.
YOU CAN SEE THE ROAD HERE IS
BLOCKED.
ISRAELI SECURITY FORCES NOT
LETTING US IN BECAUSE OF HAMAS
ROCKET FIRE.
ALL OF THIS COMES, OF COURSE, AS
THE ISRAELI MEDIA BREATHLESSLY
SPECULATES THAT A CEASE-FIRE
COULD START AS EARLY AS
TOMORROW.
BUT FOR NOW THE BOMBINGS
CONTINUE.
ISRAELI AIR STRIKES HAVE BEEN
LIGHTING UP GAZA'S SKYLINE FOR
11 DAYS NOW.
CAUSING AN INFERNO OF
DESTRUCTION ON THE GROUND.
THE MISERY IS UNRELENTING.
WHILE IN THE SOUTHERN ISRAELI
TOWN, DOZENS OF ISRAELIS AND OUR
TEAM HAD TO RUN TO THIS BOMB
SHELTER AFTER SEVERAL HAMAS
ROCKETS WERE INTERCEPTED RIGHT
ABOVE US.
IF A CEASE-FIRE IS NEAR IT
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE IT.
SINCE FIGHTING BEGAN, MORE THAN
75,000 PALESTINIANS HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED ACROSS GAZA.
MOST SEEKING REFUGE AT THESE
U.N. SCHOOLS, AND IT'S KIDS WHO
SUFFER THE MOST.
WE TALKED TO TWO 10-YEAR-OLDS
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING.
ONE ISRAELI AND ONE PALESTINIAN.
NADINE ABDEL-TAIF HAS BECOME THE
FACE OF GAZA'S CHILDREN.
>> I'M ONLY 10 --
>> Reporter: AFTER GOING VIRAL
IN THIS VIDEO.
CBS NEWS MET NADINE NEAR HER
NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH IS IN RUINS.
>> I WANT TO FEEL SAFE FOR LIKE
ONE DAY AT LEAST.
I NEVER FEEL SAFE?
MY OWN HOME.
>> Reporter: WHAT'S IT LIKE IN
YOUR HOUSE?
>> IT'S VERY SCARY.
>> Reporter: RENANA BOTZER
SWISSA LIVES IN SOUTHERN ISRAEL
JUST A FEW MILES AWAY FROM GAZA.
SHE GETS SCARED EVERY TIME HAMAS
ROCKETS ARE FIRED NEAR HER HOME.
SHE SAYS SHE KNOWS WHAT SHE
EXPERIENCES IS NOTHING COMPARED
TO WHAT NADINE DOES, AND WHEN WE
ASKED WHAT SHE'D SAY IF THEY
WERE TO EVER MEET --
>> I WOULDN'T SAY NOTHING.
I JUST WOULD HUG HER AND TELL
HER THAT I KNOW WHAT SHE FEELS.
>> Reporter: NOW ACCORDING TO
THE UNITED NATIONS CHILDREN'S
CHARITY UNICEF, ONE MILLION
PALESTINIAN CHILDREN, ONE
MILLION, FACE, QUOTE, DISASTER
IF THE CEASE-FIRE ISN'T CALLED
SOON.
GAYLE?
>> WE'RE ALL H